you can read these books totally
straightforwardly as entertainment or
you can pick up anything absolutely any
number of things I mean that's what a
reading is reading is a collaboration
between the writer and the reader
everyone in this room has a different
frame of reference a different
experience of life and anything they
read will land in a different mind in a
different imagination and they will
build a slightly different book for
themselves and it's a transaction you
know between the the the writer and the
reader I really believe that that's very
important and sort of unique to writing
and mattered to me a lot while we were
writing my reading that it means very
much you know when I was totally
isolated throughout my the first 25
years of my life you know in which I
never told anyone the truth about my
childhood they was reading which reached
me which made me feel connected with
another intelligence and another
imagination and so that arc between the
writer and the reader is a very
important thing that I believe in
passionately so I wouldn't argue with
anyone's reading of my books in the
sense you know that they're making mmm
they're making a version of it in there
right right in their own mind